Hello everyone.
Happy Environment Week Ami have.
So I liked him,
just introduced me.
I'm the founder and director of innovation at biome.
And today I'd like to talk about how nature can inspire us to revolutionize the
built environment and how we can work towards a banner metic future.
But first I want you all to sit back,
relax,
take a deep breath and I want you to imagine that you're an omnipresent,
being capable of experiencing,
feeling and observing every event,
situation and circumstance that has taken place over the last 60 years and take
it in.
What will your perception be of humanity?
Would you see humans as a transcendent species that has rapidly evolved in the
most extraordinary way,
overcoming barriers to achieve advanced levels of intelligence,
consciousness and civilization?
Or would you see a foolish species willfully ignorant of its impact upon the
world?
Would you see a collection of beautiful and unique organisms with limitless
capacity for compassion and empathy or would you see destructive levels of
arrogance and greed and an animal that has forced its own path and for Golden,
its place in the order of nature forgotten its connection with the earth and its
inhabitants forgotten the whole that we were only supposed to be a very small
part of have we created materials,
processes,
methods of governance and systems that are designed to deplete our planets of
its resources and where we really need another two planets worth of resources in
30 years time to maintain the lives that we have built and learn to love.
Have we really exhausted over half of the earth's precious resources to create
our global built environments which only form around 1% of the earth's surface.
Whilst doing that,
we also contributed to over 50% of all carbon emissions to build 1% of the
earth's surface.
Really,
would you see us as one hand working towards a common goal or just individuals
scattered,
working towards personal gain and wealth?
Would you see greed,
pain and hunger or beauty?
Compassion and love.
Is it too late?
Is this a lost cause or is the hope,
are we capable of cooperating with and learning from nature and how it managed
to build the most sustainable,
circular,
elegant and efficient environments and systems with the primary goals of
regeneration and improved health?
Well,
the answer to that last one is yes,
and there's a term for that and it's biomimetics.
Biomimetics is not the simple invitation of natural form,
but it's rather the abstraction of biological systems and processes in order to
create solutions for the world that we're living in.
The gherkin here is actually a perfect example of bond mimetics.
It may not look like natural forms,
but it's actually gone exoskeleton and has got a ventilation system which is
inspired by coral in the sea.
So it's actually a very intelligent,
efficient building using the genius of nature.
And when we rely more on biology as opposed to technology,
when we're solving a problem,
we're finding that we're using a lot more structure,
a lot more information and data and a lot less resources or substance.
We're finding that we're relying a lot less on energy and we're using all the
data that we're collecting on a daily basis and now with all the advanced
technologies and AI that's around,
we're able to make that happen.
I'm sure you know much more about that than I do and it requires a certain level
of systems thinking and systems thinking.
I'm not sure how many people here are familiar with complexity theory,
but it's the idea that the world around us consists of different systems with
inputs and outputs and when you start to see the world that way,
you start to realize that these interactions,
if you find an output that goes into the same system as an end point or another,
you create what we know now as a circular economy and that's a buzzword that
we're hearing all the time at the moment.
But in its simplest form,
we're moving away from the linear economy where we're extracting natural
resources,
we're making products in materials using carbon intensive energy intensive
processes,
and then we're using our products and disposing of them.
I'm creating ways and adding to the environmental impact and the impact on our
health and wellbeing.
When we moved towards a circular economy,
we're finding that we're starting the process by reusing recycling and ethically
sourcing materials and products and things that are already in circulation
within our economy.
We're making use in much more carbon efficient and energy efficient processes
and we're designing for deconstruction were taken into account the entire life
cycle of a product or a material.
When we're up to sign again and during the use phase,
we're introducing things like servitization.
We're extending the lifespan of a material or a product,
and at that stage we're actually adding as much value as possible.
The circular economy is not simply about recycling resources,
but it's about adding as much value as possible at every stage of the way.
So the results that you're using is not depleting and value with tool.
It's either maintaining the same value or increasing in value.
And that's exactly what we do at biome biome is a research and development led
company that places biological systems at the heart of its inspiration to create
a healthier and more sustainable built environment.
We do this through a range of biobased materials that we've developed.
We've also developed our own construction systems and we also offer a range of
services and research starting with our materials,
our focus first on all organic refuse by a compound.
And it's basically an organic binder that we've developed that can be mixed with
any food or agricultural waste to create materials that can be made into sheets
or can be molded into complex three d forms as well.
And you can achieve all sorts of aesthetics depending on the type of ways that
you're using.
And the properties of the material are also influenced by the range of waste
that we have access to.
So you can see things here like orange pill,
we could use um,
uh,
different waste streams from agriculture as well,
like hemp and,
um,
we can use sugarcane waste as well.
And we're developing that into a plant based concrete which integrates more
agricultural waste.
And we're tweaking our recipe where with our organic binder to allow it to
maintain and um,
be able to withhold a such a really high mechanical loads,
two,
two rifle concrete.
Another material we're working with is mycelium,
which you may have already heard of.
It's getting quite a lot,
a lot of publicity lately and it's basically the vegetative part of a mushroom.
If you look at any forest onto the ground,
there are giant webs of my Celia and that hold the top topsoil's together and
they allow the plants to communicate with one another.
And what we've done,
and this is known process that used in universities and companies around the
world,
is you're taking the mycelium,
you're introducing it to a waste stream or a substrate in a mold and then you're
allowing it to consume that substrate.
And what you end up with is a material just like this one here,
um,
which is actually got incredible insulation qualities.
It's self extinguishing naturally and there aren't any chemicals or additives in
it at all.
And we're developing this into a mushroom based installation or mycelium
installation.
And we're able to rival some of the premium installation that's on the market
were actually outperforming all of them as well as being able to outperform all
of the industries stances that are currently in place are currently testing and
developing the process.
You could see,
so he Locklin the eaten ice cream off on site when there was thousand degrees of
heat on the other.
Um,
and the ice cream didn't melt.
And we're also using it for,
um,
uh,
high end sort of,
products and consumer products and furniture.
But our mycelium installation is really our star product when it comes to
mycelium.
And that's because of its magical qualities when it comes to installation in
comparison to other,
um,
products that are on the market.
And especially when you think about the health and wellbeing aspects as well as
the carbon footprints and energy benefits that come with it as well.
And over on top of all of that,
we're able to be price competitive as well.
We'll introducing such radical technologies like these,
you need to ensure their survival.
And when you look at how nature ensures a species survival,
it makes sure that appropriate ecosystem exists before and in a species is
introduced.
And we were able to do that through a construction system that we've developed
bespokely for natural materials that may not be,
um,
that may not be able to withhold the types of loads that current synthetic,
uh,
alternatives are able to withstand.
And this system is inspired by the molecular structure of carbon are,
allows buildings to be deconstructed at any stage of their life because there
aren't any permanent binders or fasteners.
It's all basically a giant three d jigsaw puzzle.
And an architect can choose any floor plan and only use our 21 components to
create the building.
So it offers extreme flexibility and modularity at the same time,
which is something that's quite rare within the construction industry at the
moment.
Although mycelium and obi currently available on the market,
trigeminy is still in development and we're looking to launch it and around two
years' time,
again,
with introducing such a radical construction system,
you need to ensure that the appropriate ecosystem exists in place.
And we've done that by developing a circular business model that completely
changes the sourcing process into a revenue stream.
So instead of buying resources,
we're actually getting paid to collect resources or having them donate it to us.
We then turn them into your materials.
Those materials are then sold to industry and contractually bound to be
collected at the end of life.
And we include that in the cost of the material itself.
And we're able to do that because we're hacking the costs of the,
uh,
the actual manufacturing process by getting our resources donated or getting
paid to collect them and then using a living organism as opposed to labor and
machinery to create the actual products.
And then the building is built on site at 5% of current bill times.
We are then monitoring the building throughout its life with partners that we're
working with at the moment.
And then,
um,
any maintenance of reconfiguration that takes place throughout the building's
life is covered with a subscription service.
So we're bringing servitization to property,
which is a real game changer.
And the main reason why the housing crisis in existence is not necessarily
because there aren't enough homes in London,
but it's more because,
um,
there are the housing market is not accessible or inclusive enough for those who
are looking for homes.
And we were able to sell houses for something like 20 to 60,000 pounds and then
offer a subscription service,
which is tiny percentage of that on an annual basis.
And that's seen as an investment because at end of life you sell the uh,
the components back to us or you take them with you wherever you're going.
And it's sort of shakes up the property market and separates the value of land
and buildings,
which is quite an interesting concept that we're also looking to trial before
tracking me is launched with other modular construction systems.
Again,
you need to ensure inappropriate ecosystem exists when introducing and changing
our business models.
And we do that by holding lots of events and talks like this one.
Um,
as well as holding workshops with industry to make sure that we're able to
change perceptions and have the industry ready for what we're about to launch.
Or what we're about to bring to market and it's this sort of systems thinking
where we're constantly zooming out every step of the way and looking at the
bigger picture and making sure that our product or our invention or technology
is fitting in within the current economy in the most efficient and seamless way
possible.
About a year ago,
as Tim has mentioned,
um,
used who's the general deputy,
a deputy general manager at compass,
um,
met with our director of projects Harry and discussed orange pill.
We realized that you guys love to drink your orange trees and there's a lot of
orange peel being generated as a result of that.
And orange peels actually one of the hardest way streams to get rid of because
of its high acidity levels.
We have collected so far,
1.4 tons of the appeal that you have used,
which is 24,000 oranges.
And that's just to create some,
uh,
during the research and development process to create some products like this
one here,
which has a riser,
which hopefully you'll see in your buffet soon.
And you can see Tim is very happy with it there.
Um,
and hopefully within the next few months or at the very latest,
by the end of the year,
we would have collected over 25 tons of Po from,
uh,
your cafe here at La Plas.
And,
um,
which equates to about 450,000 oranges.
Um,
and that's just the beginning because right now we're able to achieve two to
help you be more circular and achieve circularity would our material orb and the
orange peel,
but there's almost no limit to the type of waste,
whether it's food waste or agricultural waste that we can use an orb.
And when it comes to my Caelian,
we're also developing new strains of mycelium that we're training to consume
synthetic wastes like plastics and textiles as well.
And that just brings in a whole new,
uh,
game changer to the industry.
We're introduces by recycling in a way that eliminates the toxins that exists in
our society.
One of the biggest conundrums of a circular economy is what are we going to do
with all this plastic that's circulating within our economy,
which is having huge impacts on our health and wellbeing and the environment to
every step of the way.
And this may just be the solution,
feed it to mushrooms because they can clean it up and get it out of the system.
We've achieved,
we've,
we've received a lot of recognition and awards along the way,
um,
from national bodies as well as international bodies.
And we're working with some of the largest names in the industry and that's
because we've got a really strong philosophy that really,
um,
connects with large corporations,
targets as well as a local and government and global government targets around
the world.
And we're currently going through a rapid scale up and we're going to be
launching an equity crowdfunding campaign within the next few months.
So if you're interested in that,
please do register your interest on our website because all we really want to do
is work towards a biomimetic future,
a biometric future that will not only benefit us or the people that we're
working with,
but will benefit everyone that lives in this planet,
humans or other,
um,
in a way that allows us to look at things in systems and make sure that there
are,
uh,
there's a circular economy and a future that is inspired by nature in place.
Cause that is the best way to help us reduce our time and costs.
It helps us reduce,
improve or resorts in energy efficiency and it has a dramatic positive impact on
our environmental impact.
I think we don't really need to talk much about this.
It's all over then to use that we're going through a climate crisis so there
really isn't a better time to take action with this.
Most importantly,
we're doing this to improve the impact that we're having on our health and
wellbeing because we don't see buildings as just a place that offers shelter
from the elements,
but rather they're a place that is conducive to our psychological and
physiological wellbeing and hopefully that will secure humanity's future as a
species that has achieved advanced levels of intelligence,
consciousness and civilization.
Thank you very much.
Okay,
thanks.
Thanks for,
Yep.
Okay.
That was really great and inspiring talk.
We'd just like to open it up to the floor now if anyone's got any questions.
We've got a few Mike's floating around.
If anyone wants to ask a question to a hub or myself,
Yup.
Go for it.
Uh,
really inspiring stuff while he doing there.
So I'm kind of wondering why doesn't everyone do this like this?
This seems to be like a very sensible thing to do.
So I'm,
I'm kind of surprised that this is maybe not more common.
Okay.
It's really difficult to implement such radical technologies without a really
strong network within the industry.
With government,
with academia,
we're only able to do this through the relationships and collaborations that we
have built.
So we're not doing all of this by ourselves,
but we work with really large corporations with governments and not just in the
UK but outside the UK as well.
And uh,
six universities I collaborate,
six of the top universities in Europe are cooperating with us on,
on,
on all of these advances.
So it all boils down to making the right connections and collaborations happen
to make this possible.
If you look at the certain technologies on the road and they're not necessarily
commercially viable as a standalone product,
but when you put it into this business model,
when you put it in within the whole system,
that's when it becomes really commercially viable.
So it's just connecting the dots.
It's really not rocket science.
What else?
I have a question.
Are you working just on the UK market or you star ready like um,
Arbroath plinth?
Cause as far as I know,
like for them of Scandinavia in there,
like most of the building,
some mates mood.
So England I'm not sure about it cause it's more like,
yeah.
And uh,
sorry.
And the second question,
so does your material,
um,
meet all the requirements like moisture resistance or like a strength,
another thing to build,
for example,
walls or roofing?
It's a good enough,
yeah.
So
for your first question,
um,
right now we're focusing on the UK market simply because it's where we're
starting and we have to take things one step at a time.
But we're completely open to explore opportunities around the world.
We've got a very global team from all sorts of backgrounds and disciplines and
from all over the world.
And that's always been our aim.
Um,
we've got a lot of interest in France and in Portugal and in Germany and you'll
find a lot of European countries maybe a lot more advanced than the UK was
particularly in the construction industry when it comes to using natural
materials and the perception is slightly different.
So I completely,
yeah,
I completely agree with that.
And it's something to be more than happy to explore.
Um,
with regards to our materials properties right now or buzz only really suitable
for interior architecture.
So dry lining furniture products that won't be exposed to the elements,
but we're very quickly developing into becoming completely water resistant and
be able to be used externally.
Uh,
one of the things that,
um,
architects absolutely love about Oerb is it's,
uh,
it's aesthetics and so we've got a lot of demands for using it as facades.
And that's something that we're working very hard to make possible.
Yes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
it's,
yeah.
Um,
so I was working in Poland for seven years in the building material business and
one of the things like the cuties,
that's why I'm interested in the basically and uh,
yeah,
it's like we,
we,
we felt a lot of like mood to Scandinavian mostly as I told you.
And I reckon these guys,
we'd be very interested because it's like,
like all this country's environment isn't the first place.
Yes.
And yeah,
if much release resistant and his strong,
we're going to make millions.
Well,
you can look at it right now as a,
as a comparative properties to MDF.
Um,
so you can use it in those similar,
um,
in the same applications,
but we are looking at working very hard to develop it for exterior applications
as well.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think it might be nice.
It's such on,
almost mentioned there,
but like the goal of the product is to try and make it more affordable than
what's on the market at the moment.
Absolutely.
So because of the business model that we've built,
um,
we're not only able to compete on social and environmental benefits,
but most importantly,
it's either a comparable to something like MDF,
which is seen as a really affordable material in the industry or it's just
slightly more expensive or cheaper.
And that's our aim is that we don't create a premium sustainable material.
Um,
and I think that's also what makes it quite an attractive material.
We're not trying to do this just to,
for personal gain or for pencil personal wealth,
but to offer something and create a case study and example of how sustainability
could be in a holistic way.
Oh,
it's fascinating.
I think they're doing such an amazing job.
Um,
I was wondering obviously as in when properties become a,
that the material become relevant to be external,
how scalable is it given that it's like a natural process to create this?
Could you create like towns and houses in really short periods if that is the
plan?
Yes.
So we were currently going through a scale up a process and we're looking with
our next facility to pre able to provide 20 homes worth of insulation every
month.
And that's only guided by the size of the facility that's from a 300 to 500
square meter facility.
Um,
and we're also able to build upwards and grow upwards so it's not necessarily
dependent on land use.
Um,
and so we're making sure that there aren't any a biodiversity impacts as well
from the scale up process.
Um,
and so the,
in terms of scalability,
because of the processes that we're using are very similar to Corrine,
a industry standard processes,
particularly with the old material.
It's basically just replacing a binder with an organic one and replacing the
substrate with natural substrate.
So it's a like for like replacement in terms of the manufacturing process more
or less.
How does that compare with the mushroom one?
Cause that seems like,
so with the 20 houses worth of insulation,
that's what the Mycelia material.
Um,
and it could take from four days to six weeks to grow a panel of any size and
have any volume because you can grow them all using the exact same growth cycle.
Um,
so within construction those timeframes are actually quite quick.
So it's a,
it fits quite well in terms of meeting that demand.
Yeah.
Cool.
Any more questions?
Yup.
Cool.
I was kind of wondering,
uh,
how do you see the chances if this takes on to like fix the waste stream issue?
Because like what now the incentives to properly separate your waist,
like for a company or also domestic beer on very strong.
Um,
so if,
if waste suddenly becomes more valuable because you can reuse it.
Like what,
what do you think,
what influences that going to happen?
Yeah,
so,
um,
regarding the waste streams,
there's absolutely no shortage of waste streams.
Um,
right now the amounts that we collect and during this Caleb,
they're still completely minuscule compared to the actual waste being generated
with regards to the value of ways being increased,
increased and the um,
the organizations realizing that there's a value in this resource.
Um,
we've worked on future projected business models that will help a question that
and also at that point hopefully we would have scaled enough to achieve the
right economies of scale to be able to,
to cope with that.
And other thing as well is very much like we're the way we are working with you
at the moment.
We don't only offer a waste collection service or a product to sell,
we'd like to work as a complete partnership or a long term relationship where
we're working with you to collect the waste from Italian to product,
sell it back to you and have an ongoing circular,
um,
loop happening.
So it's creating those relationships,
um,
alleviates the,
the risk of one of those partners taking advantage of the other.
Is any of this material going to be used in kg x?
One
good question.
It's certainly a journey we're on at the moment.
We've really,
I'm really keen to give as much orange pill as you can take from it and open as
many doors as we can together,
um,
to work forward towards that goal.
But I think,
yeah,
getting it scaled up to that higher level,
it would be fantastic to see.
Yeah,
that's always been the aim for us as t and tackle the construction and building
side of things more than anything because that's where he can have the largest
impact.
So yeah,
there's been some initial discussions.
Cool.
I think that's it.
Unless anyone has any more.
No.
Well,
please join me in thanking.
He had for his time and his team can come [inaudible].